c'est la fin des soldes de centre
commercial wang chen paris outlet basée
aux clayes-sous-bois note un très bon
bilan un bilan très positif pour la
raison c'est déjà emmené à ciel ouvert
donc notre clientèle est tranquille pour
venir faire son shopping puisque la
continuation est moindre nous avions de
beaux stocks
les résultats du mois de février son
exceptionnelle puisqu'on progrès sans
fil d'affable 68%
donc on espère que ça va continuer ainsi
pour attirer les clients le centre a
proposé pendant ces six semaines des
remises supplémentaires aux réductions
déjà présentes
vous êtes sur 90 magasins avec une
tendance mode avec des belles des belles
enseignes qui ont proposé des remises
allant jusqu'à 70 % pendant les soldes
additionnels aux 30% du prix outlet donc
effectivement des très très bonne
affaire sur deux très belles marques
pour la parapharmacie du centre ouverte
en octobre 2019 les soldats présents
dans les autres magasins ont été
bénéfiques
les soldes au niveau du centre nous en
commun avaient tiré pas mal de clientèle
supplémentaire la parra
quand même très moteur pour le centre
mais on travaille conjointement
justement avec la direction pour que la
fréquentation toujours en hausse les
seuils de maintenant fini le centre va
quand même continuer à proposer des
offres promotionnelles et des animations